a New York City sperm bank faces
multiple lawsuits claiming it did not
properly screen its donors for genetic
diseases the sperm bake industry is
expected to be worth more than five
billion dollars that's with a B by 2025
but some family say they're learning
very troubling information after the
fact CTM consumer investigative
correspondent that's Anna Warner has
been covering this industry and joins us
at the table to discuss what you find
out well you know you know people who
want to have a baby they spend weeks
even months selecting the perfect sperm
donor a man with a good background and
good health but these recently filed
lawsuits against one East Coast sperm
bank raised disturbing questions about
whether screening for sperm donors is
always done correctly
Andrea Frank wits and Luth Perez say
there are two daughters Michaela aged
five and Aurora two are their blessings
in life in 2013 when the couple went
looking for a sperm donor to help them
have children they came here to
Manhattan cryo Bank where they selected
an anonymous donor with a similar ethnic
background to theirs equally important
they say in his donor profile the Bank
listed the man as negative for genetic
diseases I didn't want to pass on
anything to our children because I know
from my family history there are a lot
of things that are really serious but
shortly after Aurora's birth in 2016 the
couple got this letter from Manhattan
cryo Bank telling them the donor they
chose donor number 184 was actually a
carrier for a genetic disease called
thalassemia a blood disease we're
confused on what this was because we
thought that all the genetic testing was
done what followed was six to eight
months of uncertainty and a series of
expensive genetic tests on their
daughters which eventually showed
neither girls suffered the disorder but
the couple is now suing Manhattan cryo
Bank as part of a class action claiming
the Bank improperly screened donor
samples and knowingly sold sperm that
could contain genetic diseases to
potentially hundreds or thousands of
people we want to hold him
for what they've done by selling these
donors to other families without letting
them know that you know they weren't
correctly genetically tested the couples
lawsuit is one of at least three making
similar claims one filed on behalf of a
Missouri couple who used the same donor
says their child did inherit thalassemia
which may require lifelong blood
transfusions Manhattan cryo Bank had its
inventory and trademark purchased by
California cryo Bank last July a
spokesperson for California cryo Bank
told us we are investigating these
claims that occurred prior to the
acquisition but cannot comment on active
litigation lawyer Dean Gresham
represents the families that sperm was
not in our judgment properly screened
for genetic diseases and is still being
used and sold on the market today
he says what the bank should have been
using was next-generation sequencing
technology which he says Manhattan cryo
Bank only began using in November 2014
so what is it that you're saying that
they didn't do that they should have
done what they didn't do is go back and
rescreen any of the previous donors who
had donated since 2007 for any genetic
diseases that had not been previously
screened for one of those previous
donors he says number 184 frança wits
and Perez's donor sperm banking industry
is buyers beware dove Fox is a professor
of law and bioethics studying
reproductive technology he says the
lawsuits are symptomatic of larger
problems there are no guarantees the
absence of federal state or professional
regulation at least any kind that's
enforced in any way leaves leaves
prospective parents at risk these moms
say after getting that letter they
called Manhattan Cryobank
they say they never heard back I don't
know what person in their right mind we
think that's okay
sending it off knowing that you made a
medical mistake I still don't get it all
I can think of is green
we've learned more we've reviewed emails
from California Cryobank to several of
its clients disclosing that a hold has
been placed on the use of some donor
sperm from the inventory it bought from
Manhattan cryo Bank the emails said that
the screening did not comply with FDA
requirements we reached out to the FDA
we haven't heard back yet anything you
can do to protect yourself in this case
you know it's so hard because everybody
wants to select the perfect donor yes
you know to have these children and you
think that you've got the perfect person
that everything is going to go the way
it has and I guess the word of warning
is it may not so you might want to try
to be prepared and also read your
contracts by the way especially if
you've followed all the rules and done
everything correctly and checked all the
boxes you don't have that happen it may
just be there is no perfect partner in
life and there's no perfect donor as
well that's probably a good way to sum
it up thank you very much